women I think women looking for big  goggles because it's like big you  because to me what you should be paying  attention to is who the women that are  married and it's not the ones with bbls  and blowing up lips if you look at the  women that are married they're  they're not even like tens they're like  just like I see it this is where I  disagree this is what's confusing to  women and I I understand like from my  point of view that a lot of times the  girls that are married are just bad  wives but I've had girls on the show  that are married and I look at their  Instagram and they're thoughting it up  on Instagram and it's like men put up  with a lot of [ __ ] and it's um